music
My mic's been all whack this whole time and I'm confused.
TESTING!
Whoa!
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I mean, I heard you're loading.
That's good.
Yeah.
Let me see if OBS did.
TESTING!
Oh, man.
Wait, I think...
I think you're all...
I mean, I think you're all...
I think you're not muted.
Like we are not muted.
Oh, my God!
Emily!
Emily, no way!
Hello? Hello? Hello? Hello? Hello? Hello? Hi. Hi. Hi. Can you hear? How are volume
levels? Test. Mic test. Mic test. One, two, three. Should we all just yell? Yes. I'm so
sorry. Did we peak? I don't know. All right. Reflins are reporting. They're saying hi,
mom. Right? But, but yes, it's hi, mommy equal that the volume levels are good. Come on. Yes.
They want louder and all four are clear and loud. Yes. Right. Okay. Let's go. They say the, someone
says all sound is extremely loud, but if we're all equally extremely loud. Extremely loud. And it's
even. Yeah. Yeah. I'll put it down a wee bit. By a whole three or four decibels, I'll put it down.
You're welcome. Okay. Let me see. Let me bring up the girlies. Okay. I hope everything is good on
my end. Maybe hopefully. Apparently, I'm peaking really badly, but I don't know how to fix that.
So, I'll just wait. I'll wait for next stream. We'll fix it next. It sounds fun. I just kind of
lowered you a bit on discord. Yeah, it's not fine for my stream, but it's okay, whatever.
Oh, no. Do you have a limiter on your microphone? Um, I plug in. Um, yeah, filters.
I do. I do. I tried to turn it off. Turn it off. Yeah, I turn it off. But okay,
because for me, what happened back in the day when I was using limiters is it just made my voice
like peak hard. Oh, really? Yeah, it's really weird. I turned it off. I don't know. Did that help,
chat? Did it make it worse? Did it help? Did it make it worse? I don't know.
If we think we can progress, I must demand at gunpoint. Everyone introduce themselves.
Okay, right. That's my bike. Oh, I won't let the gun.
Oh, yeah, we have guns. Yeah, guns. Who's going first?
Right. Are we all pointing at me? Me? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Go. Go.
Hi, I'm Amy Bezu from from viewers generation one indulge. Uh, yeah. Nice to meet you. Nice to
meet you. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I need a gun. Hi, I'm Fuyo, Culverfield, which printing leprechaun
a vinyl? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You have a gun. Oh, she got one. But you have a life. Hello.
Whoa. Whoa. What flashed? The gun. Oh, the gun. The gun. Guns. Oh, I see you. Hello. My name is Juno
Nagi. I'm also from Idol Corpse First Generation, Isekai, and I'm going into November. Let's go!
I said, hello. I'm Stony Cull from viewers generation one indulge, and I'm Scottish,
and I'm sorry if you can't understand that accent.
A game called kill it with fire two. He has just completed the tutorial, which means that we can
do campaign word together. We have an assortment of tools to expel this ship as we got abducted
like moments ago. And basically, we need to no more spiders. No more, no more spiders be no more.
No more spider. Fuck them spiders. There were a couple of spiders in the ship. So if you're
wondering why everything is a mess, that's why. Yeah. We had to kill him. We had to get rid of him.
A couple of spiders here. Corpse is everywhere. I do not like spiders. I don't think any of us
have played beyond this point. So what happens after this is, is what happens. I have no idea.
I almost killed them because I was just letting fire to stop. Right. Okay. No more fire. I will
use fire with purpose. I promise. I will use fire. Okay. Are we ready to go out? Are we ready to go?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm at the hangar door. Where's the door? Okay. Okay. Okay. The glowing one.
We are exterminators from space. I think so. I don't think so. Oh my gosh. There's a spider
there. Did you see it? There's a morph spider. Kill it. Kill it. Kill it. I'm burning everything.
Good job team. Burn it to death. There's a morph. What's a morph spider? Oh, what's this?
A what? Oh, what? What is that? Oh, that's the spider.
Oh, it's big. What the heck? Get it. Get it. Get it. Get it. Get it. Get it.
Bitch. Okay. Did it die? It's dead. Yeah. Did you see it back in the spider? Yes.
What is that? Another one. Another one. There's another one. What the heck?
Wow. Okay. Um, wow. We're so good at this. Clearly, clearly the shooting skills are off.
We're tearing the weights to the rack. Oh, where is the rack? Oh my. Do you even lift,
bro? Wait, do you even lift? No, I don't. Wait, there's another one. Oh my god. Oh,
what the hell? Hey. Wait, they're cheating. Is it dying? Yeah, it's dying. Okay. There we go.
Okay. Right. We're going to, while you guys are doing that, I'm going to find the weights.
There's the weight here. There's the weight here. Oh my god. I can listen to music finally.
Wait, you can hear? I can listen to music. Oh, it's a crew log. Never mind. Fuck that.
No one wants to hear that shit. Fuck that. What the hell? I love organizing. Oh, I've got more ammo
for the flamethrower. Oh, what's this? Steep pods thing in the wool bur. I think that's how we open
the hanger doors. Oh, I see. Oh, should we go? Does anyone know where the other weight racks are?
We're missing. We're tearing weights to the rack. Oh, I found one. I found one. We need one more.
Oh, we can also go through here. We need one more. The store opened. Oh, I'm searching for this.
We need one more. We need one more weight, please. Oh, there's a tape here. I'm stuck.
It's a tape. You're stuck? It's okay. I got a tape. Ring the tape back. Oh, where's the last?
I can't find it. And the tape. Oh, wait, no. What? What are you doing? Where's the last?
I got a laser gun. A laser gun? A laser gun. Wait, only you get to keep it. How do you drop it?
Is there a way to drop it? Oh, it's shared. Oh, it's shared?
Press cute. Right. I'm taking the gun off and putting the laser on. Where's the last?
Where's the last one? The weight. Hold on. I'm coming back to help you with the weight. Where's the last one?
Is there anything I can shoot? There's a bunch of weights over here. Oh, wait. That's where we put the weights.
I'm sorry. Are they behind the freaking plant? Hold it. Oh, you've come. Are they?
Oh, I found it. It was right here. I found it. Oh, oh my god, we did it. There's another one.
Oh, another. It's more compound eggs. Oh, nice.
Okay, so then we're all good, right? No more spiders or objectives in this room. I mean,
aside from over here, but I think so. We need one more audio log. Yeah. Right, we can continue
doing this cheeky holy. Cheeky holy. Cheeky holy. See, if I have Scottish, that's what I was saying.
I was extremely keep speaking. I need to hear that. I need to hear your voice.
I was explaining. I was like, I don't really like using slang too much in case people don't understand
me, but I can make my accent like super hard to understand if you want. Do it. Do it. Do it. Do it.
Right, all four of us are in at the hangar. We're currently hinting the spiders. We've
no got a clue what's about to welcome, but we're going to get our job done and then we'll get our
paycheck and we'll get it. Yes. Whoa. My car just exploded. What the hell? We started
talking about using the bridge and the hangar. It's okay. I could understand you. So I think
you could just speak however you want to speak. Yeah, everyone understood you. Don't worry. Yeah.
This is actually my real voice. I'm sorry. I've been mucking a bit for three months with that voice.
I can't be all straight anymore. All right, where'd you spray those ones?
That'll give me teleporter. You'll see. Well, oh, we need this assembler. I've just done fast travel
somewhere. Collect audio logs. A reflin says you're so good at accents. No, that's just my
actual accent. No, that's not good. Right, who wants to stand in the teleporter because I'm too scared.
I'll do it. It's over by here. I'm going up and down on the spot. If you come up,
I think this is a teleporter. And before you snag. No, I thought the teleporter was,
I thought the tele, oh, okay. Where are you? I'm back home. Wait, at the start of the map?
Yeah, yeah. Oh, it must be if you forget an objective and want to come back to do 100%.
Yeah. Yeah. Not the game devs being friendly. This game's early access. Like they've not finished it,
but the game devs are friendly like this. 10 out of 10. Oh, and there's another one here. I don't
know how to see power conduit. Okay. So we need to find stuff to fix the teleporter right here,
the big one. And I think we need to visit the other rooms. Yeah. Our objective is debug the gate's
power converters. Yeah, above my pay grade. I signed up for I was just to do the spider killing.
Okay. Oh, I got an achievement. What did you do? Solve the heart puzzle. Who did that? For you? I don't
know. I don't know who did that. You solved the riddle? I guess. Wow. What is that? Oh, my God. What
is this? Oh, I thought it was a key card, maybe. It looks like it, but wow.
Okay. There's, but there's other places that we can go that's not this room, I think. Is there?
Yeah, there's another. Yeah. Data chip missing. We're missing a data chip. Oh, wait, we have a data
chip. Oh, wait, you? That was a data chip? It's on the floor. It goes where? Oh, where? I don't
know. Where? I don't know. I don't think this is it. Let me see. Let me see. What is that thing
lighting up? I'll go the data chip. You'll never guess. I think, Nate, you go a data chip. Return
to the terminal to activate it. This terminal? Is this terminal? It looks like a terminal.
I would assume everyone gets access. Only the host may perform this action.
Your finger that's green right now. Which one?
Oh, shit, look. My sensors have detected an abnormal concentration of spiders within a
construction site. What? No one is our tourist manner along with a human space fleet. Data chip
missing. Look at me. What? Jenna, don't do it. Jenna! Wait, what happened? What happened?
It's a screen die. Jenna, like, moonwalks into a portal and my screen went black. Oh, God. Oh, no.
There's spider webs. Oh, get the, get the, oh, do fire, do fire. They're everywhere. They're everywhere.
Oh, God, kill, kill, kill, kill, fire, fire. Fire, put the knob. Kill. We're actually just secretly
arsonists on our TAMO. Oh, it's just a zoo. Burn webs. Okay. Are they dead? No.
Oh, wait. No, that was a- How many webs did- Oh, we need four more. Four more cobble
Yeah, what the fuck is this supposed to be? What? Can we open doors? Is this a normal table or-
There's a door over here that we can go through. Oh, it's a fucking deer. Burning lands. Oh, it's a
deer. It's a deer head. I want to play a game. I want to play a game. Oh, we can open that chest now.
Wait, oh, you guys are over there. Oh, yeah, there's a chest. Yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah. Wait, where did you guys go? There's a tent right here that we can open.
Wow, this house is so creepy. Guys, there's a vacuum. There's a vacuum. Everybody, there's a vacuum.
Oh, it's a cauldron. A vacuum? Which V-tubers rise up. A vacuum there. Oh, we should be tubing.
Oh, yeah. How did you guys get there? Wait, a door open. Can you guys see the spider or am I-
Is there a spider on me that you can see? I suck it. Oh, yeah. Yes. Oh, my gosh. Okay, thank you,
dude. I sucked it. This is like my third massive 10-foot spider randomly. Take it away. Don't worry
about it. They got you, Bresty. Oh, we have to brew the potion. Bresty. Bresty. Oh, shit. Oh,
shit. We got- There's some little hooligans over here. Two fires for a simmer, three for a bowl.
We have to fire up the one, two, three. Use the ladle to stir. Where's the ladle? I'm saving some
for ladle. Where's the ladle? I'm starting. Oh, Stranny has it. Stir it up. Okay. I'm stirring
the- It's working. It's actually working. Call me Gordon Ramsay because I'm not all ingredients
are in this room. Oh, my god, it exploded. Was that supposed to happen? Was that supposed to happen?
It wasn't me. It wasn't me on- You can't prove it. It wasn't me. I wasn't on the ladle.
You weren't okay. Oh, this beat- Oh, I think we might need to find another cauldron, but uh-
Wait, it's not just going to respawn. I don't know, but I think we need to- That's not how the world works.
Okay, cauldrons. Just don't respawn. Oh, how to reset your cauldron? Leave the room
close to the door behind you. Spin three times in a circle. Counterclockwise. Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, and then we have to build- We have to make this potion. So,
okay, this is the recipe. Wait, we need to- I need to get out. Okay, counterclockwise.
One, two, three, four. Oh, my god, it's this. I'm really creative. I'm gonna give them that.
Okay, I'm not gonna mix it too hard this time. A simmer. Okay, so we just need to have two fires.
Okay, so we have the two. Okay, so we need an Ivan noot and a butterfly wing. I'm assuming this is a
noot eye versus a frog eye? The only alchemy experience I have is from Skyrim, and this
ain't like Skyrim. Okay. I guess. Never leave the room in the cauldron. Oh, that's what I did.
Not all ingredients are in this room. Oh, we're gonna have to go find-
So, I think this is the bead on, and we need the butterfly wing.
Wait, where are you guys seeing the straw? Okay, never mind, I'm blind.
There are no more. Wait, I'm an extinguished fire. Only two fires are on, which we need.
Yes, only two. We only need two. Oops. There's just two, don't worry. I added more.
Oh, no, no, no, but only two are on, so you're fine. Okay, okay.
Yeah, I already put in the- I put the noot eye and the beetle in there, but we need a butterfly-
Oh, here's the butterfly wing, and we have to wait until it turns brown.
He at a boil. Don't put that mushroom. No!
It's wrong. I thought you were supposed to be in a witchcraft. What's going on here?
Hold on a minute. I thought it was your lure. I'm sorry. I'm doing this too quickly.
Everyone out. We're still spinning at me.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let me- Okay, so if I have a noot, she seems to get it.
I'm like, Jenna's the smart one out. That's really good, but it's all coming, huh?
Let's really let her cook. Are you shifting your, like, free time as well, because that ain't-
I like cooking. Clearly. Oh, he at a boil until- Okay, so we have to do that,
and it has to turn brown before we can add anything else. Okay.
Watch it not work. Oh, it's brown! In a little mushroom, right? Yes.
Yeah. And we have to wait until that turns blue.
And then- And then who wants to stir vigorously until it turns orange?
As long as it has a little- A little, and I've not got anything.
Well, you have to wait for it to turn blue, or unless I did it wrong.
No, uh, I can't find the leader, though. Hello, Mr. Leader.
I found it. It's right here. It's right here. So you have to wait for it just to turn blue,
and then- Wait, when's the green soul? I don't know.
Yeah, boil. A boil with three flames. Is it on three flames?
Yeah, and there's three. And I put that mushroom in, so.
Oh, we do it too quickly. Is that all spiders back there?
Why did they make this so hard, bro? I feel like this is actually real.
I don't have any green souls for this. Can I go inside?
This thing, you want- Why are you boiling yourself?
So you can eat me. Oh, the dining room got unlocked?
Wow. Game's telling us to go elsewhere.
God, yeah, you're kicked up.
Okay, yeah. Yeah, we're just supposed to wait, I guess, but-
Right, make it blue, and then mushroom, right? Surely.
Oh, no, no, it's not. Kill it, kill it, kill it, kill it.
I'm shit, I'm shit. Where are you? Oh, no, let's turn our wrong one.
It's gone. I think it's off.
It's gone. I think it's off. Did it die? Yeah.
I think it's gone. Is it crawling on- What is spinning?
Yeah, that break it down. Can you see that physics?
Or is it just me that sees it? I think it's just you.
It's just another- No, no, it's break dancing for me on my POV.
Hit him with a ray gun.
Oh, it's hard. Yes.
Guys, there's like a skull here.
Is it moving? Yeah.
And the light was off, so I torched it, and now it's on.
Now it's on. Wow.
Good job. Maybe it's a secret.
Maybe it's a secret.
Oh, yeah. Totally an original idea.
Not chat, help.
Did the lucky charms help, be honest?
No, totally not. Tell us the truth.
We'll get out of here.
Okay, we'll come back to the waiting room.
Oh, yeah. Oh.
I opened the door.
Oh. Oh, I found the door challenge.
Right here. Oh.
Anyone- Oh, I'm a- Oh!
Oh, my God.
Why is it yellow?
Why is it me?
It's- What do you have against yellow?
There's a shotgun over here.
There's so much happening.
Stop them.
I'm getting wet.
I'm- Oh, my God.
It's like Minecraft when you hop to the spider web.
It slows you down, bruh.
Oh, we can open this door, too.
Oh.
I need the vacuum sucker.
Whoa. Oh, there's a spider on me, I think.
Um, wait. Oh, I killed it.
Hold on. My fire thing doesn't work anymore.
What now? It's over.
What the hell?
Oh, we'll need to find the door.
How do you get rid of the- Oh, no, you-
Oh, a teleporter.
I used the nearby portal to return to the Vindicator.
Oh.
But we can still collect stuff.
Unfinished business.
Beat him up, Junov.
All right.
Okay, fire up.
Wait up.
Fuck him up.
Beat him up.
I think it's dead.
Okay.
What's this?
They're so-
How do we get- How do we go up more fire?
What the hell?
Oh, there's another gate here.
Oh, upstairs.
Right.
I don't know.
Yeah.
No.
Wait, there's so much-
Oh, there's so much.
Access to-
Get your own bathroom.
Humongous wall.
This game is far too big.
I'm so- I literally thought it was going to be like one simplistic level.
We have teleport to a different realm.
We're on a train to the back.
How do I burn this down?
Oh, there's something else here.
I need to play more.
Let us in.
No.
I'm going to shoot it.
It didn't work.
Access to hell.
Access to the bathroom.
No, hang on.
Yes?
For you.
Oh!
For me to hit you.
I love you.
I love you so much.
There's more here.
Johnny.
Oh, for me.
Oh, my gosh.
It's yellow as well.
It's so cute.
Oh, there's a-
There's a-
You guys, well, if you guys come back down,
there's a challenge thing,
but Emmie has to open it.
If you guys want to follow me real quick,
come here.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
I don't want to walk faster.
Kill spiders is sniper rifle.
Where's the sniper rifle?
In the hand.
I can't use it.
What?
Hold on.
Did anybody get a sniper rifle?
I did.
Oh, Fire Emel.
Oh.
There's more Fire Emel here.
I don't know if anybody saw it or-
Where are you?
Here, here, here.
Oh, and-
Oh.
Did you pick up all of them?
Is it on the floor?
No.
Maybe it didn't.
No, it only went to you.
Oh, okay.
Then I'm going to get rid of the-
Okay.
All right, come here.
Come here.
Coming.
Hold.
Right here.
I'm going to get rid of all of the-
Yeah.
Look, look.
Ta-dang.
Haya-kyu.
Oh, yeah.
High and seek.
Statue challenge.
Extinguished hallway candles.
While evading the spider statue.
What?
Are we playing like-
How do we extinguish it?
Is it going to fall on us?
I don't-
Is this weeping angels with spiders?
Oh, you do have to put fire on it.
Yeah, I found one.
Everybody get ready.
I'm sniping at-
Is it going to start chasing us?
I think so.
Oh, yeah.
There's-
Okay.
Oh, extinguish them.
So we have to take the fire away.
I extinguished two.
Oh.
Yeah.
I ran out of fire.
Jenna, you're actually 100 IQ.
You-
Wait, what?
Then they also pop.
It is-
It's squids.
We did it.
Is it a weeping angel?
Yeah, it is.
I looked away and then it got me.
We did it.
Okay, let me see if there is-
I hope we get the challenge.
I need spiders because-
Wait, we did it?
Yeah.
Oh, thank you.
Like, Jenna.
But I died.
You died?
Oh, it's okay.
Wait, are you dumb?
I know.
You're alive.
You're alive?
I'm back, yes.
Yeah.
Oh, right.
I want to kill the spiders with the sniper rifles.
But if you kill five, then you get another date.
Come here.
I have the sniper rifle.
Oh, there's another-
How do I get it to fire?
Oh, you have one too.
Oh, wait.
I have one.
Okay.
I did have one.
Oh, you do?
There's a skull here.
It's a skull, skull, skull.
Can I give-
Light them up.
You can light it up.
I don't know where to find more spiders.
I'm empty.
Light this up?
Yeah, light it up.
There we go.
Yeah!
What does it do?
I have no idea.
Oh, okay.
Kill spiders with the sniper rifle.
Great.
I'm looking for sputters.
There has to be.
Okay, okay.
There's a sputter there.
I don't know how to find them.
Wait, here, here, here.
There's a spider here.
Need a quarter somewhere?
Oh, it's in the clock.
It's in the clock.
Oh, I got the rifle out.
I got the rifle out.
Here.
Get it.
Kill it.
Oh, my God.
Let me give you the rifle.
Someone give me the rifle.
Let me get the rifle.
It's cute.
Press Q to equip the rifle.
Press Q to equip it.
Okay.
It should be like great save metal.
Oh.
Did you kill it?
No, no.
It's under the piano.
Piano, piano.
Chair, chair.
It's under the freaking chair.
Okay. Red seat.
Red seat.
Double seat.
Single.
I killed it.
Yes.
Oh, yes.
Oh, my God.
I don't think we need a...
You don't need...
I don't think you just zoom in.
I think it's pretty accurate.
Yeah.
Maybe.
We're running about though.
Okay.
Let's see if I can...
Oh, it's almost from a sniper?
Bruh.
Oh, this game.
Okay.
Oh, there's another flame.
Wait.
Is this an event?
Let me see.
Let me try to do this.
I have a newt.
Selfie.
You're turning the fire off, Mr. Vent.
There's a fire wave.
Oh, I see.
I don't know how to turn the vents off.
And a beetle.
Interference.
There's a morph spider nearby.
Right.
So it must be something else.
A morph spider.
Oh, it's one of those big ones.
Yeah, that come from IOM.
It's just the background.
True and bad girl.
Oh, no.
Are you a morph spider?
I'm so confused.
Is this the small mushroom?
Nope.
The mushroom is probably like a big shroom.
No, no.
Really?
No, it was a tiny one,
but now there's no more small ones.
I...
Did they respawn every time we were in the small mushroom?
There's more here.
Is it one of these?
No, no.
That's a regular sized one.
So it's a big one.
I think what it was, it didn't turn blue.
Once it turned...
Wait, no.
No, actually, you're right.
Heat until it turns brown,
then add the mushroom.
Yeah, and then...
Yeah.
Oh, it says heat out of...
Oh, royal rolling?
A rolling boil?
Oh, I guess four is rolling boil.
Does that mean put the flames back to two in the summer?
No, I think it was like I had to put all four on.
Okay.
Okay, bro, but I have no more small...
Oh, there is one.
Okay, get out.
Get out.
I'm a...
I'm a clockwise flame.
Spin on it, clockwise.
Okay, we got this.
We got this.
Wait, that's...
Is it in?
Okay, here.
I'm just...
I have a new...
Yeah.
I'm just...
Oh, I was...
Stand back.
It says there's spiders here,
but they're all dead.
Oh, no, that's what I'm saying.
Mine says there's one right in front of me.
Yeah, but they're dead.
Yeah, I don't know how to find them.
They're pretending to be dead.
All right.
Oh, he's on me.
Well, if anyone went to the floor,
I know he might be...
This guy?
Yeah, you're just...
You're just being the showroom, you know?
This is like, you've got 10 wax to go, thanks.
This is what I was supposed to do.
Oh, it's blue.
It turned blue.
Yeah.
Oh!
And that has to turn orange.
It says what I was supposed to do.
Bring to Rumble until it turns blue.
Stir vigorously until potion turns orange.
Stir vigorously.
Vigorously.
I don't know how to laugh.
Let her kick.
Keep going.
Oh, my God.
But don't leave the ladle in.
Don't leave the ladle in.
Or else it'll laugh at you.
Yeah, just turn vigorously.
But it's from the outside.
You look like it's not going inside.
You'll be like, you're just been three, six,
you'll be learning it when it comes to this, right?
Oh, like this.
Okay.
Bro.
Vigorously.
How does it do this?
How does it not?
Yes!
How do you register it not?
I don't know.
This one's just going crazy for me.
Yeah, like this.
Like this.
Oh, wait.
No.
Like, can you rotate it?
Like the bottom of it to go in?
I can hear it splashing.
So you are doing it.
Yeah.
Make it splash vigorously.
I can roll stand back just in case it explodes again.
We're like, no.
I don't want to mess it up.
How is that not done?
Is this a prank?
Are you being pranked?
I'm sorry.
Does it need to be in the cauldron?
I feel like it might need to be in the cauldron.
They're vigorously until it turns on.
It's in the cauldron for me.
Ball portion with E.
Oh, my gosh.
Firmly compress it.
I got spider.
You got it.
Yeah.
You've got grenades for sputters now.
Where?
Oh, spider.
A new thing open.
More pump that day.
Nice.
That was so hard.
What do we do with the spider potion, though?
They just.
I think it's a grenade.
Oh, god, it was a spider.
Oh, my gosh.
Clio.
Come here.
Everybody, please.
This is clear.
No, don't do it.
Don't do it.
Please don't do it.
Please, don't tell anyone.
I got it.
She's so cute.
Oh, you're back.
I'm never touching this potion again.
Are we supposed to go in the vents or something?
For that?
Oh, maybe.
Oh, that's so smart.
Wait.
Hold on.
I'm chugging.
Don't mind me.
OK.
I'm going to become.
How do I jump on a wall?
What?
It looked like it worked for a second.
Oh, I didn't.
Wait.
Can I go again?
What about the bigger one?
What about the smaller one?
What's this?
Heavy.
Oh, you got an amour.
Amour.
I can't go back to being a wee spider again.
Doesn't he like it?
Oh, wait.
I tell you why.
They choose me.
I'm off.
So, like, can you go refill the spider potion?
I assume.
I can lunge, apparently.
And then I can watch you all.
What is this?
Oh, wait.
Can you go away?
Wait, it's Johnny.
Come here.
Can you go here?
Can you go in through here?
There's a phone.
Oh, the bathroom.
Yeah, the bathroom.
Can you go in the bathroom?
Let me try.
Everyone, there's a phone and it's shining.
There's a what?
Take it.
Oh, there's a timer.
Hold on.
There's a timer.
But I know exactly what you mean.
I think I'm going to open it on the other side.
What is your timer?
Someone says accurate lit for consize.
Ooh.
Reefless.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
This was that.
Hold it.
We did it.
I got it.
It's like, I can't open the door.
There we go.
Oh, there's a spider in here.
Come here.
It's on me.
I'll just throw an open eye in.
You'll be fine.
There you go.
Okay.
I'm going to use this.
Is this blue?
It's also shiny.
It's the portions we can brew.
What?
Um, I made a brew in that.
It's shiny.
Oh.
Do you know what this means?
And again?
We're a different team.
All right, buddy.
We need to access the bedroom.
Where is the bedroom?
Um, this one?
There's no hole in to get inside there.
There is the, there's the, whoa.
There's a more spider.
That was who was in this area.
Stop it.
Spank that naughty spider.
It's got so much vitamins in it.
He's so healthy.
It's got what?
Vitamins.
Oh, how do you say it?
Slaithers source to rest.
What does that mean?
Kill all the spiders.
Fume the skulls?
Sanctity of the skulls?
Sorry.
I should have said Flintstone gummies
or whatever they're called.
That's right.
I'm coming for you.
Big Flintstone gummies.
Oh, the shiny stuff.
Bring them over to the people.
Yeah.
Oh, the shiny stuff here.
Oh, wait.
Shiny.
They went over to the people.
Oh, it's not a tube of glue.
And, uh, okay.
So we need two more shiny things.
Where did this one goes here?
There's one out here.
You're just kind of scattered around.
How do we go inside?
I've got a teapot.
I don't know.
Probably we have to get the footprints.
Is anyone British by any chance?
Is anyone British?
We're at the other shiny things for you.
I don't know.
I only found two.
Or these two?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Hold on.
If they were on this table, then yes.
Wait, only two.
We need sparkly things for the momentum.
Worry.
Sparkle.
What is this?
Right.
Be a magpie.
Sunsparkly in Chinese.
Sunsparkly.
Yes, ma'am.
Where are all these people in the pictures?
They're the people who used to live in the house.
Oh, did the spiders eat them?
Probably.
Delicious.
We need to find more sparklies.
I'm having a new look going on shiny.
How did you find two shinies in a row?
I don't know.
Oh, Fuyo custom.
Because she's a leprechaun.
Oh, that's real?
Real.
A grubby little hand.
They're waving me.
Where is it?
Replay challenge.
Absolutely no.
I'm not doing the weeping spiders from the door.
Maybe it could be inside of some drawer.
Oh, maybe.
Is it just me?
Or the color is turning black?
I think it could be from two.
Yeah, it's because we burned the base.
Okay.
Can you manually destroy cobwebs or just have to be with fire?
I think it has to be with fire.
Oh, I think it also works with the, oh no, never mind.
I thought I could back them in.
It's not working.
It says there's a more spider right here.
What the heck?
Wait, no.
It's gone.
Maybe I'm behind someone.
Oh, can you still turn into a spider?
Yes.
Come over here.
I found the bedroom, I think.
Oh, oh my God.
You are smart.
Is there another circle?
It's up here.
It's a hole.
Oh.
In the ceiling.
Go, go, go.
You do for you.
For you.
Open the door for us.
Go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh, oh.
Is it up there?
I can do some sick jumps.
Did you see that?
You're getting some air.
I'm not going to lie.
You're getting some air time.
Yeah.
Oh, why did you jump off from the?
Again.
You turned it into a human and jumping on the table was so cute.
Oh my God.
Wait, why does it cool down?
Wait, hold on.
I'll try it.
All right, let's go.
Go, go, go.
Do not do it.
You have to aim off.
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
Amy, you want to hear us talk?
Sure.
How do I do it?
Number six.
Number six is a gun.
He says to press Q and find the potion.
Oh, sorry.
My, my number six.
Okay.
All spider potions.
All right, Junna's going for it again.
Junna, go, Junna.
Junna, give me, Junna.
Give me, Junna.
Oh, you have first spider to get it.
Face it.
How do I jump?
Oh, you're doing it again.
Can I climb up walls?
That's so stupid.
Wait, it only lets you like leap on the wall.
Honestly, thank God they couldn't.
Lunge.
What?
Oh, wow.
It really doesn't let you do that.
What?
How are you so,
so there's another game mode in this game
where you like be the spider and hide from each other.
But we decided to do the campaign.
But this is.
I did it.
You did it.
Oh, nice.
Whoa.
Open the door.
Can you open the door?
I think so.
Hello.
Oh my God.
Hold on.
I'm directionally challenged.
How did you make it there?
Get down.
Up the stairs.
To the left.
Everybody.
I need one more shiny thing.
More spider.
Beat him up.
Kill it.
Okay.
I think it's dead.
One more.
Ha ha ha ha.
Another one.
Oh, we freaked us out.
Okay.
Wait, does Juna count if we kill her?
If we kill ourselves as spiders,
does that count towards the circle?
No, no.
You tried to kill Fuyah.
Maybe.
No.
It's a sacrifice I'm willing to make.
I need one more sparkly thing.
What's with the two spiders?
Spider saved.
The one in here.
Dab it.
Okay.
Hmm?
Are you going to or?
No, it's a broom.
Oh, it looks like an oar.
Whoa, that is sort.
That looks like an oar.
Oh, spider.
Oh.
Winch.
Wrench.
Spank.
There's a wrench.
Okay.
What's in here?
Is that a weapon?
Was the wrench a sparkly?
Money.
Space box?
There's currently.
Oh.
Create new weapons from.
I can't even see anything.
I'm webbed.
What is that?
Holy shit.
It was huge.
It's a plant, but it's spider shaped.
Oh.
We got it.
I'll put it on the bed.
They pranked me, bro.
No, no, no, no.
I'm destroying everything in this.
Dude, do you like the taste of that potion?
Yeah, I really do, trust.
I need to find the last shiny.
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
Suck me for you.
Oh, you became baby.
Hey.
Yeah.
Does that intimidate you?
Yes, a bit.
Oh, you need four potions?
One more shiny.
Oh, we need to make four different potions.
Yeah, I don't know how to make more, though.
It says needle drop.
Play it again.
Exterminator?
What is that on the objective?
It's on the other page of the objective.
I need to go again.
Okay.
Play it again.
Exterminator.
What is in this room?
Need to go drop.
Maybe it's the...
There's a record player here.
Is it shiny?
It's not shiny, but...
Shiny doko.
I keep accidentally drinking it.
It's like second nature now.
The other one actually did not make this easy.
That's called an addiction, Juno.
Addiction.
Oh.
I don't know how to respond.
Do we have to go back to the potion room to make more potions?
Yeah, but we need more recipes.
Can you do the same thing when we're over it at my cone?
I think it has to be different ones.
Does anyone have rifle ammo?
Upgrade module?
Oh, wait, I do.
Because we still have to kill spiders.
We still have to kill former spiders with the rifle.
There's a spider here.
Oh, yeah.
There's one here on the chest.
Strony looks for Strony.
Strony's tracking it.
Beep, beep, beep.
I'm following it.
It's on me.
Shoot it.
No, it's here.
It's here.
It's on the floor.
Oh.
Wait, where did it go?
Behind you.
Uh, red chair?
Red.
Uh, uh, uh.
Where would we find more recipes?
Yes!
Fire ammo.
Should we get it?
Yes.
Three more left.
I assume they're going to keep the Strony.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
Oh, wait, do you guys have any idea
like where to find more recipes?
In a book?
There's a more spider in Jenna's room
to the right somewhere.
If you want to snipe it with a sniper,
it's, yeah.
Where?
Here's her items.
It's somewhere here.
It's teasing.
Hmm.
It may be up.
There he is.
I got him.
Oops.
He's here somewhere.
There he is.
Oh, he's on me.
Okay.
Can you scope Jenna without taking her head off?
I don't have a head off.
Oh, Nate.
Nice.
There is another one as well.
I'm here because my jammer's still blocked.
Who is it?
Just smack everything.
Literally.
I'm just touching everything.
Is it under the floor?
I mean, under the chair?
I found it.
Oh, wait.
Nate, that motherfucker's playing.
Snipe it.
Oh, he's stuck in here if you want to touch it.
He's touched it.
And then there's one more behind us here,
somewhere behind the chair.
And we have one more bullet.
No pressure.
Oh, I found it.
It's on.
It's on Amy.
Can you snipe it with her?
Oh, I see it.
It's on my face.
Okay.
One more.
Show me.
No.
Do it.
Wait.
It's on your back.
It's moving a lot.
Show me.
Hold on.
Don't move.
Don't move already.
No.
Okay.
Boy, oh, that was amazing.
What was that?
That's the last freaking bullet.
You did it.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Got more fire, Evel.
We can unlock something now.
I don't know what, but something on the map's not even locked.
Because let me see.
Oh, not that we have to fire.
Maybe we have to like light up all the candles quickly
so that the thing doesn't get them off.
It's just work on pound eggs.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
We have enough compound.
We can go outside.
Oh, to go up.
Yeah.
Maybe that's where the last shiny thing is.
Yeah, maybe.
Here, here, here, here.
Oh, wrong one.
Where is it?
I swear to God.
There was like a seven one somewhere.
Oh.
Is that race following us?
Am I going crazy?
Is what, following us?
That's a race.
Where did you guys find the thing?
The photography thing.
I don't know.
Oh, I found that one.
I found that one.
You did?
Yeah.
Okay, so we're just missing one.
We're just missing one.
Yeah, no.
He goes in this up because he's an explorer.
That tricycle is moving.
I'm not being funny.
That tricycle's moving.
I don't need to.
Yeah, it is.
The tricycle?
You guys are going crazy.
No, it's totally.
No, it is.
If you look away.
Everyone look away from the tricycle.
I want to play a game.
Okay, look in the way.
Yes, he sees me.
I told you.
Okay, okay.
Stop looking at it.
And just let's just see where it goes.
I think it just tries to come up to us.
It probably just follows you.
Oh my God, it's turning for you.
Wait, okay.
I'm sitting on the table as well.
I'm scared of that.
I'm looking away, but I'll be on the table.
Where is it?
Okay, I look away.
Is it going to take us to like some shadow realm
if it touches us?
Oh, it stopped moving.
It stopped moving.
I wonder if it's too close.
It might be too close to it.
It just wants to play.
It just wants friends.
It's freaking moving while I'm looking at it.
I swear.
I swear there was a room that was like,
you could open it once you had like seven, maybe.
I've got a 12 one here at the ball.
Any more holes in the ceiling
that we can spider into?
Maybe.
Oh, maybe.
Maybe, maybe.
I don't know what to do.
Also, does anybody have a way to remove
planks from the walls?
I don't know.
It only lets us grab it when the nails are on the other side.
Like if the nail, if you can visually see the nails,
I think we can take it.
We have to play the record?
The record?
Oh my God, please.
Please hand hold.
Please stream snipe.
Yes, please.
There's something in there.
Someone just said, oh, nobody played the record yet.
So I thought.
Wait, hold on.
There was a record upstairs.
I was touching it.
There was.
Oh, get it.
All right.
I've got a record.
Did you complete the challenge for sure?
I don't think we completed.
Are you ready for some tunes?
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh.
I got an achievement for that.
Did it do anything?
Wow.
Maybe we unlocked something
because it said needle drop play game.
More spiders around here.
Yeah.
I'm going to smack everything.
Is that blocking us?
It is.
Who?
Motherfucker.
Wake up.
Where the fuck are you?
Literally.
We're smacking the.
I said I'm becoming a spider
and looking for the damn thing.
Oh, oh, Mr. Spider.
Where is it?
Oh, the spider is looking for you.
Someone did?
Do me one.
Ow.
Don't spank me.
When you love my lushness eight legs.
I bet you want to get all up in that.
Maybe we can hear it.
We'll make a little nest together.
Don't try to put me on the cover.
And then I'll eat you afterwards.
You think you can eat all of me?
All still in front of me?
I can find it.
I went on the.
Oh, maybe it's under the table.
Ken, no.
We still need to lay their souls to rest.
Yeah, but we need one more sparkly thing.
Right.
There's none under the table as well.
Where the heck is this more spider?
Are you sure it's not upstairs?
Because there's like a question mark.
Oh, what happened?
Oh, sorry.
I went through the portal.
Did it bring everyone?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I thought it was just really.
I don't think it's okay.
Okay.
How do we go back there?
With the recovered data chip,
you can now open the portal to dimension LAMBADO.
Wow, LAMBADO.
LAMBADO, LAMBADO.
Oh, I was like, is it LAMBADO or a dance in Spanish or something?
I mean, I mean, I'll show you the LAMBADO.
Yeah, in Portuguese, that means like a hit,
like a punch, like a slap.
LAMBADO.
Oh, it's violent.
Okay.
Yeah, it's violent.
Oh, no.
I'm not violent.
Okay, let's go.
Do my warp spider somewhere here.
We can go through the portal again.
I wonder if everything's fixed or it's like so trashed.
It'd be easier if it was fixed.
Do our own research.
What the fuck are we?
What the fuck?
Huh?
We're giants.
This is the London Mansion.
We're giants?
Downtown Arak Natopia.
Wait, but still the dimension.
I guess we have to.
You don't know where you are.
Oh, my God.
It's like everything.
Giant test proves are winning right now.
Holy moly.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Things are protected.
This is my canon size, by the way.
Real and true, though.
Yes.
I remember when you keep that.
Oh.
I love killing spiders.
You can destroy the buildings as well.
Like, screw up, destroy them.
That's so mean.
I just removed the light post.
I'll find it in the ocean.
Nobody needs rules of transit.
Take this.
Wait, where'd the spinnaker?
No, come back here.
I saw you.
Die.
Is that a mine?
I'm in the mine.
Is there a restaurant right here?
Side to side.
To the side.
Someone sniped that whole air balloon.
I ain't having it.
You know what?
I'm shooting at it.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
I didn't think they were going to actually.
Wait, what the heck?
Why is this so funny?
Strongzilla, seriously?
That's so good.
Oh, my God.
They're in the ground.
He and the sewers.
They bent it.
Get him.
Oh, my God.
I've done fire hydrants here in the North Anatopia.
Oh, there's a pizza delivery guy.
Pizza sweater.
Oh, pizza dying.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hold on.
I'm checking the radar.
Oh, wait.
There's this part that's open.
Oh.
What is this?
I see you.
Oh, I checked your dim.
I'm so bad.
I can smell you.
Whoa.
Hello, Juno.
Where did it go?
I love cleaning.
What extension surgery?
Is that what we got?
Open hydrants.
We got our kneecaps broken.
And then how do you open hydrants?
Oh.
How is there so many scooters?
You're on the bomb.
How do you go from a mansion to this?
I don't know.
Open fire hydrant.
I don't know how do you open the fire hydrants?
Juno.
You press E on them.
You press E to open the shop.
They're, like, screaming.
I feel really bad.
In the stop sign.
Do you see the stop sign?
Can you guys hear them scream?
I can hear them really bad right there.
Where's the stop sign?
In my hand.
This is my hand.
I can't see the stop sign.
It's here.
Look.
No, I can't see anything.
You can't see the stop sign?
I can't see the stop sign.
It's right here.
I'm drowning all the spiders right now.
Oh, you're drowning them.
You throw their cars in the water.
You can become a spider.
Oh.
Yeah.
I see one.
I would shoot them up.
Oh my god, you can become a spider.
Not in this version.
Spank them.
I wish I wish I wish you could kill them as a spider.
Spank them, Juno.
Why is that spider taking out?
What is this?
It's a pizza.
What's a pizza?
Oh, they have little jobs in the city.
Yeah.
We are just ruining their lives.
They're monsters.
That's okay.
Journal.
We got journal.
We're going to hit them with journal.
Oh, I need a parkour.
This gives you news whenever you kill one, I think.
That actually just reminded me.
I remember one time my dad to kill a spider
because I was too scared of it.
I was like eight years old
and he was too scared to do it as well.
Really?
Yeah, both of us were too scared.
I was like, okay.
What am I supposed to do now?
Thanks, mother.
Never ask again for help with the shooter.
Okay.
I mean, at least the spiders don't have to go to work
first thing in the morning.
Like, we're doing them a favor because it's not 9am yet.
So really, they didn't have to do a shift and then die.
They like, oh my god, it's got baker's hat on it.
Oh, now I feel a little bit bad.
Did they have to pay spider taxes on webs?
Probably.
That loaf of bread caught.
Oh, no, sorry.
That one fly.
That was 50 webs.
I'm sorry.
That was a pause.
I would have thought.
I'm going to be right back.
Hold on.
Okay.
What is it?
Defeat tanks with the...
I've not even came across a tank yet.
Out with the old.
Oh my god.
The historic buildings.
False advertising, burned billboards.
Oh, yeah.
What is this?
Destroy spider tanks.
Oh, I see.
All right.
I guess we've become tanks now.
Oh my god, it's these spider tanks.
Now they have tanks.
No, hold on a minute.
This is so funny.
We're like, Avengers level threats.
Why do they have tanks?
Are they hurting us?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
Yeah, we have health now.
They're shooting us.
Oh, really?
Oh.
All right, hold on.
We are the real spiders.
Oh, Chinese can be a little tank.
I'm a tank.
I'm a fight back.
You did it with tanks.
I'm a tank.
Wait, did we do it?
I'll show them a juggernaut.
We can destroy the buildings.
Yeah.
We're more challenge complete.
Oh.
Wow.
That was easy.
We did it.
We're so good.
All right, there's another spider here.
Oh my god.
Do you see this?
Like the spiders set you liberty?
Oh, destroy it.
Destroy it.
That's landmark.
Hold on.
Oh.
That's nice.
If you don't know, I'm shooting it.
I'm shooting it.
No, wait.
Right.
I'm going to be a little tank.
And then I'm going to throw my bullets at it.
Yeah, throw it.
Shooting it doesn't do anything to it.
Yeah, it's not really working.
Allow me.
I might be small, but my tank.
Oh, no, my tank is far too short.
Hold on a minute.
But come here.
Come here.
I mean, I'm going to see if I can get to the edge.
Come on.
No, that's so tiny.
That's so tiny.
Nice.
Is it going to hit?
Can I aim higher?
I can't see anything from up here, babe.
Is it working?
Aim straight up.
That's like as high as I can go.
Oh, shit.
I literally cannot see anything.
Did we get an RPG?
We must get an RPG this map.
Come on.
Get me an RPG right now.
I'm off the edge.
Wait, we have to collect 30 spider hats and accessories.
I don't know how to.
When you kill them, if you look at the floor,
there's so many like little hats.
They have hats?
Yeah, you can.
Oh, I love robbing them.
I love robbing their dead bodies.
We're pillaging them.
Oh, I see.
That's how you get the hats.
Oh, yeah.
I love stealing from spiders.
Did we already go on this thing?
No, we must go because there's destroyed buildings over here.
Oh, my God.
OK, there's like two main islands.
Right.
I'm going to look for hats though.
Their screams are so sad.
It's OK.
Remember what they did to us long ago?
Exactly.
What did they do?
What do you think this is?
Oh, OK.
I'm not going to accidentally go through that.
Does anyone have any later fluid?
I can tell from the real that we are the real monsters.
No.
No, no, no.
Why do you say that?
I don't know.
You don't know?
This is a hunch?
Maybe I'm just being self-conscious.
Just a little bit.
It's OK.
You're not doing anything wrong.
Yeah, you're right.
Yo, dim, steal their hats.
Big spider.
We're like balloons in boats.
Don't mind if I do.
Oh, my God.
My aim is so shit.
What's with the balloons?
Oh.
Wait, you can actually shoot the balloons?
Yeah, yeah.
If you shoot the balloons, it's a part of one of the milestones.
We need like four more balloons.
I shot two.
A boat as well.
If you see a boat in the water, shoot a boat.
A boat.
OK.
Yum, yum, yum.
Finest cuisines.
The most historic.
Oh.
OK.
I know what the historic buildings are.
Oh, the billboard.
How does that bridge up?
What a pathetic little stream here.
Oh, no.
Fuyo said this thickness is coming out.
Wait, what is this?
I got a burrito.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, we have to destroy all the...
We have to get the foods, too.
The cuisine.
Oh, for the billboard.
Yeah, you have to, on the buildings.
Yeah.
They have food on their buildings.
This game is like way bigger than I would ever have expected.
Like, way bigger.
It is really big.
A cuisine.
It's very silly.
It is a nice thing to do, Fuyo.
Although, I'm starting to feel a wee bit bad,
but like, here's them screaming, run away.
I'm like, ew.
You're starting to feel a little new of hearts right now.
Too real.
Too real stuff.
Yeah, like, I don't want to, like,
start wildly attacking them.
Oh, shit.
There's a bunch over here.
Oh, there's, like, challenges on the antenna.
Oh, in order to say, oh, my, that's so cool.
If you...
Someone go come back next.
Collect.
If you destroy.
One more.
Oh, kill.
We have to kill one more spider.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
It's so, like, when you destroy these buildings inside,
there's the crystals.
Oh, right.
Destroy every single building.
Gotta, I'm beating them up.
Okay.
Say no more.
The crystals are in there.
Okay.
That's cool.
We will deal with...
Are they in a particularly colored building?
Yeah, but like, you have to finish the objectives
in order to open them.
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay.
I see.
Purple building.
Purple buildings.
Okay, I see.
Purple building.
The mollusk historic buildings.
Okay.
This was a historical building.
Destroy balloons in both.
Did we liberate statue one?
I can't figure it out.
Destroy it, but maybe...
Maybe later.
Oh, did we not destroy all the historic...
Oh, no, I think this is the last historic building.
Hold on.
What, the Statue of Liberty?
There's a...
Did I not?
Maybe a lighthouse?
I saw a lighthouse earlier.
Oh, look at that spinning thing over there.
What is that?
Okay, we need one more.
What you see in it?
And maybe...
Oh, there's a purple one.
Oh.
Okay, one more historical building.
The historical building's just like older
than the other buildings, if that helps.
There's billboards.
Oh.
Oh, there's one over here.
Yeah.
I think...
They got that detailed...
Where?
Oh, yeah, yeah, kill it.
I'm killing it.
Eat it down.
I think that's it, right?
There's blood here.
Is it destroyed?
I still can't open it.
I think...
Oh, I guess not.
I don't have any more ammo.
Can I shoot it?
I don't know how you're supposed to...
Close everything.
What building is it?
I love an outfit.
But it looks destroyed.
Huh.
Oh.
Shoot it.
Oh, no, it could destroy a sister.
Yeah.
Yeah, I do.
Thank you.
Destroy everything.
Wait, you have to defeat tanks in the RC tank.
Is it tank time?
Wait, would it be faster to blow up the building with tanks?
Yeah, probably.
That's what they're for.
But how do we see the other tanks?
Yeah, that's way faster.
Oh, really?
Wait, how do you become a tank?
I'm going to destroy every small potion.
You have to find the...
In the queue, if you press Q.
You can find the tank control.
It's like a little cart that you control.
Oh, so cute.
Oh, look, it's another recipe.
Wait, for the...
For the witch thing?
Yeah, look.
Oh, my God, it all connects together.
Oh, so you have to like keep going back and forth?
Maybe?
I guess so.
I mean, the adorable orange tank.
Hey, did I not see...
Oh, this.
There's a spider there.
Rad cola.
Keep smelling.
There's a screenshot.
Rad cola.
Do we have to write that down?
Do we have to write the recipe now?
We have three more fighters.
I drone.
Maybe we should screenshot it.
I screenshotted it.
Organize.
Okay.
What other objectives do we have to feed?
We still need to drone them.
They are not making this easy.
I need another...
I need another balloon.
I'm going to drone another one.
How do you drone them?
Throw the cars.
They'll be attached in IOM if you use the v-scanner.
And then yeet into the water.
That's messed up.
Okay.
We need to also burn two more billboards.
Oh, I see one.
Billboards.
Why did they make this so controversial?
But this seems difficult.
Like there's so many layers to...
You have to watch yourself slowly become the villain.
Yeet.
You live long enough to become the villain.
Oh, there's a billboard.
Oh, wait.
No, I think it's already destroyed.
Already burned?
Okay, okay, okay.
I need...
We need to drone one more bitch.
Throw their cars into the ocean.
Got it.
I don't...
I think that bridge that we can't get past this one
that needs 20 freaking rocks.
Yeah.
Everything else is.
So I don't think they go back to like another teleport.
Basically.
I see.
That would be my guess right now
because I don't have one more splitter.
Oh, my God.
There's billboards over there.
Oh, I found one more billboard.
Oh, you did?
Yeah.
I should have break every building.
A historic building.
Historic building.
Let me see.
There's any other cars here.
So I can drown one.
One more billboard and we unlock another like purple.
Oh, I drowned one.
Nice.
What did you do?
Okay, I opened this one.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Beat it up.
Destroy it.
Show his balls.
Show us his balls.
Vacuuming it.
You're stuck.
Vacuum melting.
Yeah.
Yeah, we did it.
Right.
So that's their team.
So we can go back to that haunted mansion
and do the bottom door on the floor.
Oh, I found another billboard.
Wait.
Oh, you got it?
That's the last one.
Yeah.
Okay.
You did it.
We got another one.
Oh, my God.
It's all coming together.
It's all coming together now.
Oh, my God.
But we just didn't drown one more little bitch.
No, no, Foo, you did it.
She did it.
I already did it.
She drowned it and we got it.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, we did it.
Destroy another balloon thing then.
Okay.
Is this a historical building?
I think it is.
Yeah.
I just see you guys.
Did we destroy a historical building?
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Whoa.
I see it.
No, it's not one.
Okay.
That's 15.
How much is the bridge?
20 or something?
20.
Oh, that's rough.
I think we may have to go back to the witch's culture.
I want to go back.
Also, your body friggin...
When you're hitting things with the newspaper,
your body just contorts.
Dude, there's no more air balloons.
I think it must be visible behind those buildings.
Yeah.
Maybe we...
Also, we missed the chance to defeat tanks with the tank.
Oops.
Yeah.
Oh, I think we need like five.
I think we maybe need to restart it.
If Emi goes to one of the antennas to restart...
Yeah.
There might be more tanks in the next town over.
What's your tunnel?
The antennas is over here.
There's one over here.
Oh, yeah.
It like starts a minigame.
Yeah.
And we can redo it.
Destroy spider tanks.
Okay.
This is the one.
We're strong enough.
Yeah.
We can redo it.
Oh, that one?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to turn into a tank and then we should...
Get the tanks, everybody.
Okay.
I'm ready.
All right.
Wait, hold on.
My tank is far away.
Pond me all the way over here.
Are they serious?
Should I?
Because that's where you left it.
Oh.
It gets left on the right.
I'm very slowly coming over.
Beep.
All right.
I'll come over too.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Oh, you can recall it.
Hi, Johnny.
You're coming in.
We're coming in.
They see us rolling.
You can recall it.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Okay.
That makes sense so much easier.
Try to catch me red and dirty.
Oh, there is a red state in there.
Okay, okay.
Okay, four years ahead.
We're coming.
And you're not red, okay.
Okay.
So now, once Emmy activates the mission,
we'll all jump in tanks and go mental.
Yay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's time to explode.
I'm very slowly coming.
Oh.
I mean...
Try to catch me red and dirty.
All right.
I'm not saying that.
Okay, ready?
Ready?
I did it.
Yes.
Oh, it took me out.
Where are they?
Are you joking me?
I took me out of the tank only to...
Oh, there's the other team.
Oh, why am I in the...
I see them.
Green.
Should the green?
Green bad.
I'm trying to change them.
Wait, it's not even...
Okay.
...hitting.
Is it registered?
Is it working for you guys?
Yes, but it's not a single kill.
Very badly.
It's not like a one kill hit.
You have to hit multiple times.
I'm spraying.
Okay.
Okay, that's three.
That's three.
Two more.
Two more ladies and clean.
Okay.
My tank exploded.
Oh, no.
My team's gonna die, too.
It's okay.
Where are they?
They're in the center.
Oh.
No, I did it.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
It's clicking.
I think it's clicking.
Oh, my God.
Right.
Now we can go be up a building.
Whatever one it may be.
See, I...
This one?
The pink highlight.
Yeah.
It's like a green question mark on the map.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Oh, my God.
We did it.
We're balling.
That's a great team.
They're straight up balling.
They're straight up extermination.
We're playing worlds of cancer at least.
Nice.
Now you have 60.
Early access game.
This is massive.
This is early access?
Yeah.
This isn't even the full release.
This is like 0.6.
What?
You're not even like close to implement
what you want to do.
Huh?
Ooh, money.
I just stole money from a spider.
Oh, oh, my God.
What a gangster.
Oh, wait.
No, it was Emma.
Oh.
How do you do that?
That makes it slightly better.
Oh, that we can shoot.
I don't get it.
That's what I'm saying.
Like, I was...
It's probably...
Maybe there's another objective
or there's another mini game too.
That's just like kills spiders.
Maybe some hot air balloon ones
will appear.
Right?
It's over here.
I think they're shooting things at us.
What?
There must be soldiers.
Soldier ants.
Go away.
No, ants.
Okay, no, spitters.
Spitters.
Yeah, this one's just for the soldier ones.
Should I activate it?
Yeah.
Okay.
Just to see what'll happen, right?
Kill soldier spiders before the timer expires.
Oh, this is another one.
Right.
Run, run.
Get them, get them, get them, get them, get them.
Hunt them down, hunt them down.
Make them regret being born.
Oh, my God.
Oh, they're in tanks.
They're in tanks.
Oh, my God.
Right, let's say everyone's getting burnt alive.
I have terrible aim.
It's over.
Geneva convention's out the window.
I'm on a rampage.
All right.
Okay, we've got seven.
We've got seven.
We're doing it.
Come on, keep going.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, this is so satisfying.
I feel like this is wrong.
They're trying to run away.
It's a great way to release stress.
Challenge complete.
Ray, that's another one.
Let's freaking go.
We're doing it.
Yeah.
Ray, I guess there's nothing we can do.
I didn't unlock anything.
Yeah.
Ray, my controversial take is we need to go back
to the witch's place now.
More.
I know.
It was controversial.
I'm sorry if we get canceled over that statement.
It is.
What it is.
Oh, we're going.
We got to go.
I'm ready.
Okay.
And her.
Ready.
Only the host.
Oh, right.
Okay.
We're going.
Hydration check.
Oh, water.
Drink your water.
I don't have water.
But I have a droplet device to you.
Cheers.
What?
Oh, look at all the stuff that we can go to though.
Like before we do that.
Yeah.
Explore the ship.
That's so much.
Okay.
It's finally clicking in my head how this game
mechanic works.
I'm sorry.
It took me an hour and a half.
This is literally a Metroidvania game.
You still work bench and army to equip.
Oh, to upgrade.
Hi, Darwin.
You found your way in.
Excellent.
If you discover any.
Yeah, you have a lot.
Oh, wait.
There is like a.
Okay.
Oh, well, I regret that.
Oh, we can.
Okay.
Oh, upgrade.
I'm always object.
Okay.
They're absolutely all over this lab.
Don't be surprised when you open a like a.
Oh, there it.
Get it.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I'm close them because we destroyed them.
Oh, oh, oh, shit.
There's a pack of punch in this game.
Like call it like literally called zombies.
We've got pack a bunch.
We can upgrade the extra like damaging or something.
Oh, what do you guys want to upgrade?
I don't know.
Oh, we just got an extra.
Okay.
Oh, we can be open this now.
Open it.
Let's just give you a great points.
Oh, I didn't think the locker is a thing.
Nice.
Compound eggs.
Let's go.
Close it up.
Okay.
And then go here.
I'm with the science team.
The science team.
We're going to the science team.
Oh, only the host can do upgrades.
Where's the upgrade?
Oh, I have a laser assault.
In any any dark room.
Oh, there's a spider here.
Where?
Oh, I'll beat him.
It was there was a spider.
Oh, this is like the crocodile game.
To create equipment from a blueprint.
You grabbed like three ball things.
So I don't know if you guys have that.
Purchase here.
Okay.
Let's make a new weapon with the blueprint then.
Oh, there's a spider.
Teleporter.
Create new equipment.
Oh, the Molotov.
Oh.
Oh, did the Molotov.
Oh, there's a Molotov.
Okay.
This shuriken.
We can be nature's.
Amy, we need your help.
Amy, what do I do?
Oh, we need you to press this button as a host.
Which button?
Over here.
This is print the hollow Molotov.
I did it.
Yeah, we require the objective.
Completed.
Yeah.
Okay.
We need two more access to the Molotovs.
If you press Q.
Q.
I've named Molotovs.
What?
Molotovs.
I got six.
Oh.
Let me check these bullets.
Did you also do that?
Let me see.
Molotov.
Excuse me, I also burned the lab in a very unsafe way.
Ah, spider.
I'm just okay.
Okay.
We need one more.
One more?
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Can you upgrade anything for in our armory thing?
Yeah, here, here, here.
Wait, I forgot where it was actually.
Over here.
And then we'll have 20.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here, here, here.
And then we can run fast.
Huh?
Run fast?
Use the workbench to upgrade your-
Here, here, here.
You can upgrade things.
Oh, yeah.
If you upgrade your quick board, we'll run fast forward.
We have 20 now.
We did it?
Yeah, we did it.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Wait, so we go back to the time?
We have like nine upgrade points.
We can upgrade basically everything.
Yeah.
So everything becomes-
Eh?
Who's that?
Oh, whoa.
Oh, my God.
I just got splooged on.
By whom?
My holy duty did not to me.
A spider.
Ew.
Sorry, it was my anchor.
Go excited.
Oh, sorry.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
Hmm.
Actually, if you're an eel, can you-
No.
Huh?
Maybe?
What?
Can you slime if you're an eel?
No.
I think those are a little slimy.
I don't think people know a lot about how eel slime.
Oh, wait, we can open this.
Wait, come here.
But you know, do you see the 20?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's do it, let's do it.
Let's do it.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
I think we can get that generator thing.
Yeah, we can get that generator thing.
Why don't we get that convenient?
The command thing.
I think we can take this.
Oh, wait.
Let's open this.
There's already dead spiders in this area.
I don't trust them.
Kill zombie spiders.
They're going to come back to life.
They're not dead.
Undead.
Spongebob.
Welcome to the command wing.
There's three.
There are eight zombie spiders we need to perish.
Or nor.
Right here.
Where are you guys sharing numbers in chat right now?
Wait, what?
We are.
Oh, if they die in need of each other,
they've come back to life.
Wait, they just keep coming over and over?
Oh, sorry.
If they die near each other.
Oh.
I think we take this to the, hold on.
I'll go.
I'm going to TP.
Oh, there's another rich.
So is all of them restarting?
Or just?
Yeah.
Oh, they're dead.
They're more than dead.
Oh, they are back.
They're like back in the whole,
like in the captain's chair and everything.
Yeah.
You know what, nuke time.
No, screw it.
Tank time.
We have molotovs.
So I'm just burning everything.
Oh, my God.
Just burn everything now.
Burn it all then.
Oh, my God.
There's so many.
I don't see any.
Am I blind?
I don't see any either.
I'm just hitting stuff with them.
I mean, I'm hearing them getting burned.
That's why I use the flamethrower a lot.
Oh, it just burns them.
Wait, why is that?
Oh, there's one.
What's this?
Beat them up.
Recess pop.
Wait, we have a tracker.
We can just find them easily.
Hold on.
I can hear.
I would like access to it, please.
Who would have killed his director
if he's currently stuck in lockdown?
Fuck you.
How do they?
Please.
I can't grab the fucking tape.
Oh.
Where did the tape?
Is the glass really in the way right now?
I don't know if I had to.
Oh.
I think there's a way.
You can shoot the glass.
Oh, there we go.
It was like burning like to a cinder,
so it wasn't happening.
Nothing screened.
Oh.
Oh, guys.
Chest.
I don't know what's in here.
Oh, one more.
Compound X.
My E is the fourth.
Chest.
Yeah, this chest had a compound.
I think so.
We need to compound now, so.
What do we do with the compound?
What?
No, it's not a compound.
I thought it was zombies.
Zombies aren't real.
This is poor at a theory, though.
Well, we go back to the teleport again to the new area,
because we've unlocked so many new things
like in the other area.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Where's the teleport?
Oh, the serotonin on my brain from unlocking things.
I don't think there's anything else we can do here.
Did we ever find all of the dumbbells?
No.
Yes, we did.
We did.
I didn't know it.
Okay.
Also, I unlocked something,
so now we can shoot with this,
but I don't understand it.
I don't know where we're supposed to shoot with this.
Can we shoot the whole spider planet down?
No.
Wait.
Maybe eventually.
Eventually.
That way.
I swear.
I don't know how to do that.
I opened up a teleporter over here,
so you can control it from above.
Whoa, like a bird's eye view.
No, you just look at it from the screen.
Yeah.
Find a way through the reactor blast.
Oh, the reactor blast door.
Where's the reactor blast door?
It's probably this whole thing.
The red stuff, these red things right here.
Oh.
Oh, I know.
The reactor doors to the right there at 3 o'clock, so maybe.
Oh, can you aim there?
Can you aim?
Oh, I can see the thing turning around very slowly.
Yeah.
Okay, yeah.
I'm aiming.
I'm shooting.
Shoot it.
They really couldn't have made that any slower, could they?
No.
It's very slow.
It's okay.
Patience.
I feel myself aging.
Oh, it is moving.
I didn't even notice.
Moving slowly, but surely.
I wish we could break the window.
Yeah, like, aim it at the window.
Don't aim it at us, but at the window.
Well, it may actually kill some spiders in the room at random.
So that might be it.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Just a little bit more.
A little up, a little up.
I think that's good.
That's enough.
Just go a little up.
Excuse me, will the kill spider behind us?
Is it working?
I don't know what we're supposed to do.
Was there an instruction?
Should I get this?
Oh, you can talk to Darwin.
You can talk to Darwin.
Ring the least of the reactor blast door.
Some disassembly required.
I just...
There's no way that's supposed to be able to aim all the way over, right?
Unless it's...
I'm no convinced.
I'm no curious.
Reactor blast door.
Control America's furniture.
It's time to put your brain cells together.
Come on.
You need to...
I don't understand.
I don't like thinking.
This sign says reactor.
So maybe we should do this.
The door?
Yeah, that's what I was thinking,
but I don't know how to aim it.
I think you can.
And then down.
Hold on.
I think I...
Like that.
It told us...
It told us that Darwin said for this door,
imagine little spiders and tanks.
So I think we have to go back to the giant test world and destroy it.
I don't know.
Darwin randomly just made a reference to the wee ants and tanks.
That was my one and only attempt at small talk,
and then that's it.
He doesn't see anything there.
Oh.
Oh, dude, I used the tube.
Can you tell for me?
No.
What's this?
Destination control.
Ow!
I did it!
Good job!
Wait, no way that worked.
Yeah!
Wait, did you have to shoot me?
100.
I had to shoot the door.
No, but you shot me and then...
Yeah.
What is that?
Oh, this knife died.
Burning them in case there's a sputter in them.
Oh, and there it is.
Yeah.
Wow.
What's in here?
Why is this powerful?
We reactivate the tailpipe.
Oh, my God.
It's like the tail room.
Long way around.
This room is B.
Fuel cell.
Oh, there's a spider here.
A zombie spider thing.
Oh, that's good.
Nope.
You don't need to locate 3 out of the 6.
Fuel cells and calibrate the gate.
This is...
Okay, I found one.
I found one.
Oh, here's another.
Oh, I lied.
So one of the fuel cells is in the ventilator system
that connects to the reactor.
Yes.
Wait, that connects the reactor to the control room.
There's something here.
I'm really bad at directions.
Fuel runs into the reactor core.
So ventilator system?
What about the others?
What is the fuel run?
There is also a very large life form in that section.
Is it a little quiet in class life form?
Oh, wait.
We can become a wee spider, can't we?
Maybe.
I think we can.
Also, we need to put something in the reactor
and I don't understand what it means.
What is it?
Oh, coming soon.
Fuel runs.
Yes.
I don't know where to get them though.
Wait, how are you coming?
Only the host may perform this action.
Begin challenge.
Sneak through.
Oh, did you try this at me?
Or not yet?
I can't open up.
Oh.
Right, sneak through the vent.
Is this a boss fight?
I don't know.
I'm just going to cry.
I hope not.
Why do we have health?
Oh.
Get ready.
Don't worry about it.
Hacked.
Use the tracker to detect nearby spiders.
Oh, there's nothing here for now.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait.
We're not going to attack them?
I guess not.
Let them pass?
I guess we're just trying to sneak through.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
I think it's my fault.
Don't worry.
I have a fire.
Oh, abomination.
Abomination, level 30.
Okay.
No, okay.
Firebird, bird bird.
I'm just thinking kill it.
I don't want to do the old methods of hanging over me.
Oh, god.
I'm getting out of there.
That thing's to be stopped.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Apple it.
Oh, my god.
Why are we hitting it in slow motion?
I just died.
I died.
I think it was worth it.
I think you're faster when you're crouching.
Let's probably get this.
Oh, right.
Get this.
Get it, get it, get it, get it, get it.
It's not me.
I don't think we got it.
Bro, that did not.
That was some low level.
Oh, we're up here now.
Yeah.
We're in the control room.
I wanted to kill it though.
We have a teleport now.
Oh, spiders are not as cunning as they think.
Scans are just many of the vindicators have stolen.
Okay.
We need one more.
One more, what?
Should I just not frustrated with Darwin?
I'm sorry.
It just happened.
I mean, we should have a captain's quarters.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a morph one here as well.
We find them guarded.
Best of luck, bitch.
Not you, but...
Oh, is this another teleporting thing?
Yes, we can come and then out of this room as much as we can.
Please, no.
Oh, no, this, this thing.
What's this?
The teleport.
Bridge.
No, but this.
What I'm holding.
Oh, all right.
It's like this.
Wait, wait.
Where are you?
I put on the ground with this.
I thought those were key codes,
but they weren't last time.
I think it's just the...
Yeah, true.
Oh, it's three.
Okay.
Let me double check.
Can't we still have the other one?
Maybe we should put them in the same place so we don't lose it.
Okay.
Complete vent challenges through the vindicator.
Wait, there's more vent challenges like that?
Three.
I'm just running past.
I'm not.
Another compound.
What?
So we need one more cell thing.
We need one more?
Yes.
I forgot where the last one is.
What's his name?
The...
The viewers that Darwin...
Darwin told us.
Yeah.
Captain's headquarters.
Oh, oh, that's probably the room we spawned in.
Mmm.
Oh, so then there should be one over there, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
This is Armory.
Wait, wasn't there one in the Armory?
I've got a wrong one.
KitKit Launcher?
What the hell?
What is it?
Another one?
Difficulty hard.
Right.
I think our best approach is going for it.
I think our best approach is just going for it.
I don't know if it's going to, like, help us grow.
Oh, wait, it might walk across.
Hold on.
Or maybe.
I don't know.
No, it's not walking across.
Right, I'm going to take a right.
If you guys want to split up and watch out.
Oh, shit.
Go right, go right, go right, go right, go right, go right, go right.
Oh, no, I'm out of freaking fluid.
I don't have any...
Oh, I said Molotov.
Like, jeez, that is an epileptic seizure waiting to happen.
That, like...
Oh, my God.
You did?
Go, continue on.
I'm going, I'm going.
Continue onwards.
I've got it, I've got it, I've got it.
I see it, I see it as long as the freaking spider doesn't...
Let's go.
Okay, I've got it, I've got it, we're out.
Oh, my God.
Oh, where are the...
It was gone from high up.
Wow.
Oh, wow, okay.
We made it.
Okay.
Oh, there's a green on the map, though.
We can open up stuff.
Oh.
Yeah.
One more green, right?
I'm going to put the refuel.
My serotonin is through.
Serotonin.
Challenge.
I got 25.
We did it.
We've got 25 compounds.
I don't know what that means.
Nice.
That we can do, but I'll take it.
This is the long teleport.
I didn't mean that one.
Hold on.
This.
How do we get inside here?
Oh, and I'm back at the point.
Compound X across all dimensions.
We need 35.
How do I get upstairs?
There's something up there.
Huh?
There's a question mark upstairs.
Oh, like, I'll do it up there.
Oh, oh, oh, it's one over here.
Yeah.
Oh, yes.
Okay.
And inside the chest is another compound X.
Probably.
Yep.
Right.
One more.
But there's 23 in the ship, according to, like, the top
left compound X.
Flames thrower.
Oh.
We're still the kill zombie spiders.
We've only killed five so far.
No, I don't know where they are.
Keep watch of the vents.
Wait, seriously?
I was getting, one of the reflins said, look out for the vents.
Do you mean to?
There's a venting.
Is that what, is that a hint to what we're supposed to do right now?
Are we, are we, are we supposed to, are we supposed to do that?
I wish to be sus and then wonka.
Didn't I already do this one?
Choose wisely.
What is this mean?
Oh, fuck.
It's another vent.
Oh, I guess you have to choose.
Choose where to go with.
Choose what spider to go with.
What's that?
Spiders are going to.
Spider?
Oh, the spider's good.
Well, there's a baddie over there.
I'm off.
I'm.
Okay, we can choose.
We can keep going there ahead.
What the?
Wait, what?
Huh?
All right.
Don't look at that.
If you're epileptic, close your eyes because I don't know why they put that in game.
Not epileptic.
Wait, there's so many red.
There's a lot of abominations around.
I know where it is.
Oh, wait, there's more than one?
Oh, jeez.
There's a lot.
There's abomination right there.
Wait, we're to pay one.
How are we supposed to know where it is?
What the fuck is this?
Oh, it's following us.
Oh, shit.
I don't know how I've done it, but I found it again.
Oh, I did?
I don't know how I keep doing this, but.
Oh, my God.
I think I have the gamer instinct because I've got it again.
Right.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, so we need two more.
Two more?
Two more.
We have two.
Oh, okay.
Do we have time?
Yeah, there should be one more from event thing and another one.
Is it this one?
Oh, no.
This one's complete.
Yeah, and so we need to do one more event and there should be one more in the overworld for us to find.
I just don't know where.
Is this a ventilation shaft?
Maybe it's this one.
Oh, is it?
Is it this?
Oh, ring around.
Well, we did do this one.
Okay.
This choice is complete.
Yeah.
What the flip?
Flap, Italy, duck, tick, tick, patty, walk.
Can I find it?
We do this.
Oh, oh, we did do this one.
Is it by the zombie ones?
I wish there was a map in this ship.
Oh, wait, there's a question mark.
Hold on a minute.
I want to ask a question more.
Wait, what?
I can see a green question mark in this room as if...
Wait, that's one of the ventilations.
We need to get in there.
Yeah.
Oh, are we going to have to...
Can we go back to the mansion?
I want to go back to the mansion.
Yeah, I think that's the next step.
Oh, go back to the mansion and then we'll call it a day.
Mansion, mansion, mansion, wow.
We need to find one more sparkly thing.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, oh, we must put...
But now we have unlocked stuff, right?
Yeah, there'll be a low on the map rate.
Uh, does Emmy have to select mansion?
I'm coming.
Emmy is coming.
Yeah.
Emmy, Emmy.
A manor.
Um, target dimension manor activate.
Yes.
Okay.
Let's go.
Wow.
We're doing it.
Okay.
Great.
Oh, is it trash?
Is it reset?
No, okay.
That's fine.
Oh, it just makes...
That just makes finding stuff easier.
Oh, but there's spiders all over again.
Oh, my God.
But there's so many stuff like that we can go into now.
How do we lay their souls to rest?
We need to find another sparkly thing.
Magpie tie.
Okay.
There's a really weird room under this.
Oh, there's a basement.
Yeah.
If anyone wants...
Oh.
Yes.
Is this how we go outside?
Okay.
Maybe.
I hope there's a shiny thing in here.
Oh, there's a green thing over there.
Oh, it's here.
What is this?
You found the shiny?
I found the green thing.
Oh, what is...
Oh, it's...
Oh, it's on the compound.
There's one.
Engine on me.
Yeah, more compound.
What's in here?
Magpie.
Access the kitchen and welcome.
Access the kitchen.
Oh, that shouldn't be too hard.
Oh, the shiny items aren't here again.
Oh, wait, I found one.
The basement.
Oh, wait, they are here.
Oh.
Wait, are they back?
Okay, found one.
Oh, that's the newest one.
Oh.
Yeah, where's the others?
Are they where they were supposed to be at the beginning?
You can jump by a freaking spider.
They're jumping me.
God damn.
Yes, they are.
They are where they spawn.
Oh.
Okay, I found the iPhone phone.
Okay, that way, that's so nice.
Where was the other one?
How do I go through this window?
As a spider, maybe?
Break it, or you can break it, too.
Okay, another shiny one.
We are just missing one shiny.
It might be in the cauldron, please.
Let me see.
Yeah, I think that's the one.
Um, I can't see it.
But I think it was you who found that one specific shiny.
I found these.
I don't know where it is.
I think it was the-
Oh, the photograph?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it was the photographing thing.
I don't know where that was.
I got so close to getting through the door.
I mean, through the window.
Oh, you got this.
I have to wait for the cooldown.
Oh, where is it?
I don't know.
You're the one who found the camera.
I have no idea where it is.
Okay.
What is this?
The bedroom?
Oh, I got it out.
I got it.
It's not random.
It's in the same places.
You got the camera?
No, I got the shiny.
Look, oh, the compound X on the run.
Is that not what I was-
Oh, okay.
Well, I accessed the balcony.
Nice.
Oh, God, big spider.
What is this stuff?
I think it was just perspective.
Never mind.
Okay.
Why is there-
I can hold a brew?
Dude, I don't know where the-
Can you kill the spider?
Oh, yes.
Burn through it.
Hold on.
I got really bad aim.
Give me a second.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Okay.
Nice.
We only need one more painting thing.
Yeah, I don't know where it is.
Oh, I think his goes here.
Oh.
Yeah.
Well, what's on the balcony?
Not much.
Jeez.
A teapot.
Oh.
What's it?
Oh, the cauldron.
It was the cauldron?
Okay.
Let me see.
I'll check all the drawers.
What the-
Oh, I thought that was like a person sitting.
I was like, what the fuck?
They're waiting for you.
There's ghosts here.
Okay.
Got it.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh, I'm running out of freaking-
Has anyone found the kitchen?
The kitchen?
The kitchen.
I don't know.
The camera is.
Wait, I saw a camera at one point, but I don't know-
Where?
Yeah, I found a camera at one point,
and I didn't know what to do with it,
so I didn't touch it.
Where is it?
I don't know.
I don't remember now.
Oh, no.
I was going to just fight it on my face.
Oh, come here.
Thank you.
It's still on my face.
There we go.
It's dead.
I'm not kidding.
I found the camera.
Uh-oh.
There's a mission and a basement for the old spooky one
where you have to like-
Where are you moving to?
Just so you know.
We'll have to do that in EJ.
There's a big spider there.
I don't know if I killed it.
And you didn't see the camera in here?
No, but also I didn't look very well.
Oh, rich.
Oh.
The camera wasn't in there?
I don't know where the camera was.
My brain hurts.
Let me-
Uh, if I was a camera, where would I hide?
You've already been in the bedroom.
It wasn't in the witch's cauldron?
I don't think so.
Is it in the closet?
Not.
I might have not looked correctly.
I mean, like the camera would be in the bathroom.
Sus, Sus.
Why would you put clothes in there?
For fun, Chas.
We didn't have access to the balcony either, did we?
Yeah, but Amy opened it.
Yeah.
I saw the camera on a shelf.
I might have thrown it somewhere though.
Oh, I found the camera.
Oh, no.
I found it.
It's okay.
There we go.
You did?
Yeah, I did it.
Okay, help me.
I didn't.
I don't know.
I'm stuck in the basement.
I don't know how to get out.
No, I actually did it.
29.
Let's go.
Okay, so there's so four more things that we can do here.
So, in the basement, we need to get cans of peaches.
I've done six, but I couldn't get the rest.
The basement's down there.
Oh, yeah.
I got one more.
Seven.
Yeah.
Okay.
Right.
Then the stairs into the ray is stuck.
Oh.
So, you have to find cans of peaches?
Yeah, literally.
Peaches, peaches, peaches.
Okay.
I found one more.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches.
I
You know get through here
And all
If we can finish the matter, I'll happily wrap up after the matter cuz okay
Yeah, three we have to do three we have to get three more peaches
Oh
It's okay, it's okay. I was just trying to get in here. Oh shit. I got in there, but I walked out damn it
Oh wait, you didn't have to turn to this way
How many more kinds of peaches do we need three
Oh, I think I found one. Yeah
Hit him with a okay now two more
One more blue
Or oh, and then we do the security spider game
Okay, I hear whacking that can't tell if it's you guys or if it's like that's me
Like the location of stuff
No, that was me. Don't worry
How do we get on this side? Am I done?
How'd you guys get on that side?
This is just like all the way around you need to do like a little 360
Oh
Is that out the window? Wait, if we can smash these windows. No, okay. I was gonna say that would be really cruel game design
Is it dev team? We have a problem
Where is it?
Wait, how about we do the scary spider statue thingy? Maybe it'll reveal itself. Yeah, maybe
Uh, I don't even know where
What's scary you got this the aim
One
How you call it the weeping angels
There's like one in the hallway somewhere. I don't know where it is, but I'll try and find it. It's over
I thought it was over here. You mean you lost
Oh, wait. No, that's all here. I'm at it. Look where strong is jumping up and down on the spot. Okay
Oh, okay
One of us should be looking at us basement candles while evading the spider statue, right? I'm gonna stare at the statue then
If you guys want to blow on the
Okay, I got one. I got one. I got two
Whoa
Where's the rest?
Is there two more?
Yeah
He's not for it. I must be scarier when you're playing solo because it will be like yeah
After you, but yeah, we're just cheating the system. I ain't blinking. Oh, here's I got another one. I ain't blinking
How many more do we need? One more one more. I found it. I found it. Wait. I thought I did
Oh, never mind
I did not one more. Oh, yeah, I guess I did it. This is three out of four now
I think
Don't don't put it back on if we have to say I can get the light away
Are you putting them back on?
No, no
Oh, we have to get rid of the lights. Yeah. Yeah
Wait, then how do you extinguish them? Do you just kind of hit them? You are the board
Do I also turn off the lights? How do you turn off the
Oh, no, it's just the skulls. We only have 40 seconds left
Oh my god
Wait, I didn't count
It didn't huh
Well, I count it. Oh, I felt you'll never guess where the last kind of pictures was where was it?
It was made what the hell?
Oh my god machine at the start now. So that's oh my god
Okay
Now we only need we only need to get uh, what is it?
Three more of the crystals
Well, we try and finish I think so and then
Wrap up the cheeky knit. Wait, what we don't even know what the access the kitchen and the balcony
who's
Access the kitchen. Where's the
I'm I'm assuming the kitchen is this
Where
Right here. Yeah
I'll go make another potion and see if it counts towards the oh, yeah. Yeah
Let me see let me pull up my screenshot
We did not didn't don't tell for
And
Like and I don't I don't think so. Why would they not leave that?
Oh, no, so bring it to a simmer
Okay, you have the recipe, right?
Yes, add one femur. Okay. What?
That wasn't me
Is that not a fever?
Fever a leg bone
Yeah
Yeah, this one
Yeah, I put it in and explode it. I didn't like it. Well, then try it again
Maybe it's going to do with the fire and first. Oh the bank back for hon and us. Fuck you
No beach. Who's back?
Okay, I need to spend any clockwise a couple of times. Okay. There we go
What happens when we finish the femurs because we only have one more theme. Oh, no, there's another one here
Yeah, but we'll leave us alone tricycle. We're trying to make femur in here. Put it in. Oh
Yeah, I don't know the femur. Do you have to put the potion here? Like yeah, is it the amount of fire? Oh
Are you did you do two fires? Oh
Maybe maybe I had to like break open the building more
What do you mean break the building more is it like incomplete?
No, like maybe
Maybe I don't know how to explain it. Maybe I had a like
Completely destroyed the building so that it came out or something, you know, like the fire
Did you do the can we try to guess fire?
I did two fires. Yeah. Oh
That try I'm not on the trace. I'm one with the tricycle. There's four fires
Oh
No, no, no for simmer. It's just two but yeah, if I put it in explodes
And do we have to do simmer? Do we have to do something else?
That is a femur. A femur is a boom. Yeah
Yeah, this is bringing me into a simmer add one femur stir until potion takes a rosy hue add one to be a femur
This is a femur. Where's the tibia? Maybe this is the tibia
Yeah, this is the largest bone in the human body. So whatever one looks the biggest
Yeah
No, they're not the same. Look at them. They're a little different
Okay, the weird one will be the tibia
Wait, which one is the tibia? Where's the tibia? Okay? I don't know. I'm a smaller one few cheeky spins
Then you worry, I'll keep you straight when it comes to biology
Okay
Okay, I ready
What they look the same
No, no, no
Look at the femur. Yeah, that one the one that foo use hold and look at the hip
That's the hip on the top of the femur. Yeah, right two two two fires in the summer before you put it in
Okay
femur
No
I don't
I'm why have I did not register that? I don't understand. I don't know
Simmers fires. Is there any fire mentioned on your screenshot or is it literally like? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, it's just bring cauldron to a simmer
it's too
Yeah, I think I had a break open the building completely
Yeah
Yeah, two fires is a simmer
Then do we have to leave the two fires for a little bit?
No, I don't think so
I think the game's being annoying. Hold on. We never came out into the circle
How do we open the
Oh, sorry, I didn't call it wise I didn't call it wise. It's okay
I guess I I think I did have to like break open the building more
Do you want to go back or well? No, I was gonna say are we wrapping it up?
We're wrapping it up
Okay, what's the thing?
I mean, I'm pretty satisfied with how much progress we made because I was playing for how
Like seeing that game go all the phone went in
No way it works this time
Is it because for you something
I understand for you
You're
That'll be the look of years making it
A spider on your face. It's okay. I would whack but I don't want to break the cauldron. I'm just gonna
Well, there you go. Hold on. Hold on. It's still there
I don't know. I killed it mixing the magic potion
Dude
I have no idea where that's not working. I think it might have worked because you let it simmer for a little bit
Really should have thought about that before having impatient players
I can't believe it doesn't instantly work right away after we followed the instructions
Well, thank you for inviting us. It was really really fun. Thank you for coming. I was well good. I didn't expect I honestly like
Didn't expect it because it he did the tiny things but thank you so much for entertaining us as well
Like this is a hit in the hauler
I kind of want to play this again. This is really fun
Yeah
I think if we made progress faster it maybe would have dragged a wee bit less
But I think now that we understand the core element
Yeah, I understand. I already get the core element now
Yeah, but thank you so much for seeing us. Thank you for inviting us
Thank you. Do you guys have any announcements?
No, thanks. No
No? No announcements?
What do you mean?
Do you have an what would you want an announcement? Hold on you go first. No
No, no, no, no, I was just thinking if there's anything like fun that's gonna happen soon for you guys
Oh, I can't leak a secret. Yeah, I'm not allowed to leak it. I'm unfortunately
Oh gosh
I didn't know no, there's no secrets that's not been announced. There's no secret
I totally didn't leak it to jenna before we started but no no secrets at all. Nope
Okay, okay
Um, I'll leave the game I guess
Um
Everyone's still on my screen too
Um here, um, I didn't see everyone still talking
Quick collab. There we go. Kick them all out
Um
I'm so so sorry for my mic. I don't know why it's broken
I'm sorry if I was being quiet
um
like
A little bit less than halfway through the collab. I suddenly felt really sick again like yesterday
So I was just being a little quiet
um
Because if I talk I'm gonna puke so
I will leave you here. Um, thank you for watching the collab
I'll see you. Um
Maybe tomorrow, um, okay
Thank you. Have a have a good rest of your day
Okay, bye
You